bonsoir à tous et merci de nous
retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro de
kiosques que votre émission culturelle
sur 50 ans ni ville et ses environs tout
de suite
le sommaire de ce mercredi 10 février un
plateau électro pop fera vibrer la
batterie de vue en cours samedi 13
février à 20h30 pour l'évoquer en
plateau le groupe hdr qui revient avec
son nouvel opus de touristes un album
pop aux instrumentaux planant et
psychédélique un jeudi 18 février 20h30
ce sera au tour de base à ré bémol
d'enflammer la scène de la batterie de
guyancourt spécialiste du désordre
musicale organisée ils sont en plateau
pour nous parler chanson française folk
reggae et bossa nova la galerie d'alfred
de vigny de voisins-le-bretonneux
accueille jusqu'au 19 février
l'exposition douceur obscur et brumeuse
un travail d'auteur en noir et blanc qui
réunit trois photographes claude chose
denis duclos et stéphane bretons en
plateau avec moi deux groupes de musique
les hdr alias housse de racket
avec victor le masne et pierre leroux et
en face le groupe bazar et bémol avec
cherche ronan et raphaël bonsoir à vous
alors en plus de rejoindre bientôt la
scène de la batterie de guyancourt vous
avez d'autres points communs vous étiez
tous amis respectivement avant de former
vos groupes musicaux
vous avez des noms groupe très originaux
je crois qu'on peut le dire et vous êtes
tous des musiciens issus du
conservatoire ou en t on ou en tout cas
d'école de musique
ce qui amène une vraie complicité
musicale dans vos morceaux alors on va
commencer avec vous victor hyper vous
serez sur la scène de la batterie donc
samedi 13 février à 20h30 vous êtes
originaire de chaville vous êtes
rencontrés adolescents au conservatoire
et vous étiez un peu les renégats du
conservatoire c'est ça un petit peu
ouais enfin c'est on sera conservateur
on avait 15 ans un truc comme ça où on
commençait un petit peu a décroché le
conservatoire on avait un peu envie de
d'aller vers les instruments un petit
peu plus amplifiée électroniques et
électriques
et c'est vrai que ont joué du bernstein
ou un truc comme ça et victor portait un
tee shirt de de pearl jam à l'époque et
c'est vrai que l'on a
on a tilté quoi ces jarres bombe à
moquer de lui il est à part et moi aussi
je crois donc on va je vais aller parler
à ce mec au fond alors c'était quand
même une bonne formation parce que vous
avez tout de même appris à jouer de la
batterie des percussions et de la
guitare votre groupe à 10 ans et vous
l'aviez nommé à l'époque housse de
racket
victor peut être l'explication de ce nom
c'est un nom très spécial mais ça prouve
aussi que c'est on n'avait aucun plan de
carrière quand on a fait ce qu on avait
ce groupe c ac c'est vraiment de la
vraie spontanéité et de la vraie
honnêteté et puis en fait de fil en
aiguille on avait commencé à faire des
morceaux instrumentaux au départ parce
qu'on est à boire instrumentistes avant
d'être chanteur et il a fallu appeler le
nom du dossier ça on appelait ça ou vous
aura 4 mai et puis de fil en aiguille on
a eu un manager on a commencé à faire un
concert puis un deuxième puis un album
chez machin etc
finalement ces régimes et donc sa prise
de raquette trop bizarre mais mais mais
pourquoi pas en fait c'est je pense
c'est aussi la musique qui fait que le
nom est intéressant en fait alors je me
tourne également vers bazar et mal parce
que votre nom interpelle également
pourquoi bazaris mémoire bazar et bémol
c'est ça représente en fait l'esprit
vraiment du groupe dans la musique
autant aussi comme on est dans la vie
c'est une sorte de joyeux bordel
organisé de mettre un bémol sur un bazar
ses toiles à adoucir le bazar c'est que
ça veut dire bazar et bémol est donc on
retrouve ça dans notre musique
d'accord on parlera un petit peu après
de ce joyeux bordel organisé
victor pierre votre nom évolué de housse
de racket on glisse tout doucement vers
hdr une transition à l'image d'une
évolution musicale pierre a priori non
après l'énoncé on and on est fidèle à
notre musique est assez juste on
réalise peut-être tardivement que ce nom
prend un peu trop de place aussi et
qu'il est temps de changer un petit peu
de véhicules pour l'essai de la musique
s'exprimer pleinement en fait donc oui
bien sûr que l'on va là où c'est notre
troisième album il ya une évolution
naturelle mais qui est pas spécialement
lier un lifting dans le nom le nom en
tout cas alors vous vous le dites donc
un soc le musical qui est commun à ces
années c'est dix années de groupe pour
hdr vos mentors on peut les citer david
bowie stevie wonder les beatles et
michael jackson cet ami tort c'est ça au
début on était vraiment autour de la
musique funk blague c'est vraiment
stevie wonder arsenal fire était
vraiment les les débuts et puis après on
fait on est arrivés vers david bowie
parce qu'il ya autant arroser la musique
très très froid de limite minimale
allemande a un truc très très black donc
david bowie c'est peut-être la personne
et ses 1000 carrière c'est qui nous a le
plus évolué reconnais c'est vraiment ce
talent de se réinventer à chaque album
c'est un truc qui nous inspire beaucoup
de livres encore plus loin parce que
c'est le look ses limites son nom de
personnage à chaque fois donc peut-être
peut-être david bowie même si c'est pas
parce qu'il est mort récemment mais
c'est un vrai truc qui nous apportait
alors le grand public vous a découvert
en 2008 avec oyez depuis vous avez sorti
deux albums et après deux ans de tournée
mondiale vous revenez en france avec un
troisième album the tourist on écoute
tout de suite un extrait
jega
m
alors cet album est sorti le 30 octobre
dernier il est disponible sur toutes les
plateformes de musique et ce sont
justement ces deux années de tournée
mondiale qui vous ont particulièrement
inspiré pour cet album c'est sa pierre
abce absolument et aussi le fait d'être
rentré après deux ans de tournée en
ayant été au japon en colombie aux états
unis et c'est peut-être quand même assez
nomades pendant deux ans est subitement
de rentrer chez soi et de dette
justement très sédentaire et de regarder
par la fenêtre puisque voilà le clip
qu'on vient de voir a été tourné au
dessus de mon appartement donc face au
sacré coeur où j'ai emménagé à la suite
de cette tournée et il y avait vraiment
tout est un paradoxe ou d'un seul coup
on devenait nous les touristes de notre
propre quartier on avait juste à
regarder par la fenêtre
voir les gens du monde entier de venir
en fait dans notre vie à nous en fait
donc ça c'était un peu le point de
départ un peu de ce2 se disent quoi il
ya un peu un blues aussi au fait de
revenir à la maison et tout se dire je
rends compte que ce qui se passe
maintenant
d'où le nom de l'album the tourist donc
vous y parlez d'exotisme de géographie
et justement les morceaux évolue
progressivement en anglais cette fois ci
n'y a plus que deux morceaux en français
c'est un choix c'est comment ça c'est
fait il fait beau gentil skalli pyatt
cette tournée donc beaucoup à l'étranger
est en fait de l'anglais est vraiment
rentré dans notre vie aussi puisque
pendant deux ans on n'était pas trop en
france donc on parlait surtout en
anglais je veux dire avec les gens
limite on avait des expressions qui nous
qui nous venaient et c'est donc c'était
presque nature de syndrome jean claude
van damme est très proche mais il faut
faire un don et gaieté mes premières
années le premier album était vraiment
entièrement français parce que c'était
notre vie on était français parisien etc
voilà deuxième album c'était un peu en
entre eux deux et troisième album était
complètement ailleurs
donc
voilà peut-être que le quatrième album
sera un retour aux français ou à
l'allemande
cette voile à l'envi de s'ouvrir au
monde alors de la pop électro toujours
pour cet album avec des instrumentaux
planant et psychédélique pour certains
vous êtes associé d'ailleurs samedi donc
on le disait pour un plateau spécial pop
électro à la batterie de guyancourt
samedi 13 février à 20h30 au groupe
qu'ils aient à l'inrs on dit de votre
musique que c'est une musique
cinématographique est ce qu'on entend
par là je pense que ce qui nous a plu à
la base dans la musique c'est en avant
mais on avait ce point commun la
victoire quand on s'est rencontrés c'est
quand on adorait regarder les cds à
l'époque et de revoir les des timings et
les durées des morceaux en fait et
combien manceau qui duré 9 minutes on
sait à ce jour celui là ça date un bon
morceau dure neuf minutes ce qui est
complètement débile en fait mais mais en
tout cas nous ça nous plaisait l'espèce
de de deux voyages en fait qu'aucun
morceau et voilà donc vous aux touristes
si c'est ça pour moi la musique c'est un
voyage depuis toujours donc
donc voilà avant d'être parolier et
chanteur
voilà on est compositeur et quoi de
mieux que des instrumentaux long pour
exprimer aussi des choses avant même de
mettre du texte c'est parce qu'il ya des
mots que sara compte moins de choses
quoi alors avec vous base à rimogne la
musique est peut être un peu moins
cinématographique mais très variés c'est
de la composition à base de chansons
françaises qu'on appelle la nouvelle
scène française
il ya également du jazz du reggae du
funk on va d'ailleurs écouter trois
extraits qui sont tous sortis de votre
premier album
alors le premier c'est votre morceau
insomnies extrait bazaris bémol on a un
cachet
je crois que c'est l'heure de la danse
donc vous avez avant ont produit deux ep
là c'est votre premier album intitulé le
fruit du bazar sortie en juin 2015 un
opus de 13 titres disponibles alors
physiquement on peut le retrouver en
magasin est également sur toutes les
plateformes musicales alors un deuxième
titre maintenant autochtones
badens et va jamais le risque
comment peut-on rêver les voyages quand
on n'aime pas les voyageurs et un
troisième pour le plaisir tiré de votre
titre ramoneur
font ça on est leur fille
alors on l'a entendu vraiment trois
extraits très dansant mais pas forcément
tout à fait sûr les mêmes sonorités
pourquoi ne pas avoir voulu s'inscrire
dans un style de musique particulier
chez ge cherche
parce que à la base en fait on était
parti sur un style particulier qu'était
la chanson française de façon à
peut-être un petit peu traditionnelle et
petit à petit c'est simple on au fur et
à mesure des années qui passent on ne
veut pas faire tout le temps forcément
la même musique non qu'on s'est enrichie
d'autres d'autres choses dans notre
culture musicale qu'on a apporté à notre
musique donc un peu de jazz un peu de
funk un peu de rock par ci par là
voilà c'est juste parce que ça évolue
tout avec les années on évolue
d'accord ou non vous associez en plus
des instruments différents comme la
trompette et la contrebasse à la guitare
et aux percussions pour créer toujours
ce thème mélodique un peu jazzy un peu
funky
c'est vraiment un dénominateur commun
votre musique la multiplicité des
instruments effectivement on en fait
tous au moins deux instruments nous ça a
été assez naturel on n'a pas réfléchi
conceptuellement la chose à la base mais
on ne me faisait plusieurs instruments
nous avons envie de faire ça ça apporte
de la diversité pour nous pour le public
du rythme et une richesse musicale
justement avec un panel tu vas donc de
la trompette au cajon et en passant par
la basse la guitare et puis les trois
voies qui forme aussi une harmonie assez
importante donc c2c de la diversité de
la richesse qui est important certain
rythme et qui nous plaît quand rafa
d'ailleurs cette richesse musicale on la
retrouve aussi bien dans le jeu au
morceau que sur les jeux de sonorités
dans votre texte
alors les textes on nous
on les met aussi en avant même si la
musique est très importante et on aime
beaucoup justement que au delà du fond
que la forme aussi soit soit ces belles
pas là on s'inspire des plus grands
comme brassens pour ça brassens les
ordres de barback d un éventail
d'inspiration vous serez donc sur la
scène de la batterie jeudi 18 février
20h30 pour un plateau de chansons
françaises dynamique et festif
alors on pourra d'ailleurs vous
retrouvez également le 13 février à
marcq du côté de bell le 14 février à
villiers le mahieu le 18 donc à la
batterie de guyancourt et le 20 février
à la bellevilloise vous êtes des
routiers des concerts vous avez déjà
votre actif plus de trois cent cinquante
dates et vous avez l'habitude de partir
chaque été deux mois sur les routes pour
sillonner festivals concerts et
spectacles de rue c'est un moment
privilégié pour les rencontres chache
pour les rencontres c'est de nous une
bonne façon de tester les chansons
souvent on fait donc sur notre tournée
fait plutôt juin à septembre va dire à
peu près sur les routes et donc ce soit
une tournée on présente les chansons
habituel et on en profite parfois pour
jouer un petit peu dans la rue entre les
entre les concerts qui sont programmés
pour tester des nouvelles chansons et
puis voir l'accueil qu'on a auprès du
public donc ouest nous permet de
rencontrer nos publics de cette façon là
d'une façon un peu de billets par
rapport aux concerts plus plus classique
c'est intense on est donc que tous les
trois ensemble et on crée aussi beaucoup
plus on est en place au plus de chansons
ça nourrit aux influences aussi
forcément d'une certaine manière puisque
c'est quand même deux trois mois dans
l'année et que ça fait partie de la vie
donc forcément ça nourrit
après on ne sait pas le moment on écrit
le plus c'est mon plus on est en place
on travaille ensemble en fait voilà un
peu important et qui existe il est vrai
depuis la création du groupe et qu'on
continue chaque année c'est quelque
chose auquel vous tenez particulièrement
rappelle d'ailleurs parce que vous avez
démarré par l'école de la rue
l'école du métro c'est une école
particulièrement formatrice vous trouvez
oui complètement justement que
ça permet de tester les morceaux devant
un public et pas du tout conquis
d'avancé
donc voilà on a pu jouer beaucoup comme
ça et sélectionner un peu les meilleurs
morceaux les maires transition et puis
ça nous a permis aussi de rencontrer
sorte de professionnels aussi qu'il
fasse dans le métro comme comme tout un
chacun de trouver des dates de concerts
des réalisateurs de clips etc
et puis de faire du public pour nos
concerts c'est donc une bonne école
alors tout autre spectacle je vous
propose maintenant une conférence
humoristique le spectacle basique
einstein ce sera vendredi 12 février à
20h30 à l'espace albert camus de
maurepas un voyage plein d'humour à
travers à la physique l'astronomie et la
philosophie
dix places sont offertes retrouvez
toutes les informations sur le site de
tv fil 78 tout de suite un extrait de
basic einstein mais nous allons tenir
aujourd'hui font faire un grand voyage
dans l'immensité du temps vont rejoindre
l'univers 15 millions de degrés je sais
pas si vous imaginez ça veut dire tout
la barre quand tu veux te faire les yeux
durs et bien le temps de les bombes des
gens à tous les anti
quand de la science il voudra parler si
tu t'y prends comme un manche qui pourra
te brosser merci vous 5 d'avoir répondu
à notre invitation et je rappelle que
l'on pourra retrouver hdr en concert à
la batterie de guyancourt samedi 13
février à 20h30 et leur album également
ce touriste sur toutes les plateformes
musicales et pour base avarie bémol ce
sera le jeudi 18 février à 20h30
toujours à la batterie de guyancourt est
également votre album le fruit du bazar
en physiquement donc en magasin et sur
les plates formes musicales
on parle de photographies maintenant
avec une exposition monochrome présenté
par la galerie d'alfred de vigny de
voisins-le-bretonneux jusqu'au 19
février une exposition intitulée douceur
obscur et brumeuse qui réunit trois
photographes claude chose ses fans
bretons et denis duclos apparu à la fin
des années 1860 la photo couleur est
aujourd'hui la plus répandue dans le 8e
art le monochrome continue néanmoins de
séduire les photographes qui trouve dans
ce style une manière d'aller à
l'essentiel de l'expression de leurs
rares à l'image de stéphane bretons qui
parle noir et blanc illustrent le
ressenti d'un renoncement au travers de
son exposition ziad le noir et blanc
pour qu'une autre réalité que je
trouvais intéressante également une
sorte d'intemporalité le noir et blanc
ont fait partie de l'histoire de la
photographie et on est même une
singularité par rapport au cinéma par
exemple sa porte
un trait d'union entre je crois le
ressenti que peut partager tous les fils
des hommes sur terre à la fois dans
l'univers site alité mais également dans
l'intemporalité
le noir et blanc permet de mettre en
valeur les formes et l'éclairage du
sujet d'un cliché cet effet de contraste
est souvent associé aux jeux de
brouillard à la manière de brassaï ou
encore comme le propose claude chose qui
nous fait visiter les jardins du château
de versailles avec sa série manière de
montrer les jardins de versailles la
couleur n'aurait pas apporté grand chose
et je voulais que les gens se
concentrent sur le sujet plus que sur la
couleur la couleur souvent fait perdre
l'intérêt du sujet donc parce que il ya
de belles couleurs et des raclées
souhaitait que le brouillard m'apporte
ce côté cotonneux qui amène aussi les
les regardant généré à un peu à imaginer
ce qu'il en est
la galerie d'alfred de vigny rennais
jusqu'au 19 février le travail d'auteurs
en noir et blanc de stéphane bretons
claude choses et denis du clos avec sa
série graphique
in memoriam représentant un système
supposé ordonnée qui a perdu le contact
avec la raison humaine témoignage du
mémorial de l'holocauste à berlin et
place au cinéma maintenant tout de suite
vos réactions sur les nouveautés à
l'affiché cette semaine au micro de
camille lambert
moi je sors de là enchanté voilà j'ai
bien fini entre l'état et puis j'ai ma
deuxième qui est enceinte alors c'est
vraiment j'ai l'impression de vivre
l'histoire
non non c'est très très très sympa très
bien joué bon moi je trouve que c'est
quand même un peu lourd mais il ya
vraiment des passages où
on rit le scénario est pas super il n'y
a pas de y'a pas d'effets surprise n'est
pas celle attendue quand il était bien
il a respecté toutes ses promesses et
ouais franchement à revoir
c'était vraiment génial cd de kool tout
craché mais vraiment des blagues à gogo
c'était génial c'est bien c'est bien il
ya plein d'humour moi j'ai bien aimé ça
change
et cette semaine c'est marilyn pouls du
cinéma les yeux d'elsa de saint cyr
l'école qui nous donne son coup de coeur
de professionnels le coup de coeur des
yeux d'elsa c'est carole de todd haynes
qu'on va jouer la semaine du 10 et du 17
février en version française et en
version originale sous titrée c'est le
film qui était à cannes et qui a eu le
prix d'interprétation féminine pour
rooney mara et que cate blanchette
aurait mérité également tant elle est
sublime dans ce film c'est l'histoire
d'une
d'une rencontre amoureuse donc entre
thérèse qu'une jeune employée dans un
magasin et carole king
une bourgeoise qui en plein en plein
divorce donc une rencontre a priori qui
ne devrait pas arriver et ce film est
vraiment senti autant au niveau de la
mise en scène que de l'image on est dans
les années 50
donc c'est un mélo mais vraiment un mélo
flamboyant
on n'est plus dans l'imagination
amoureuse que là
la passion elle même on est vraiment
dans dans la tête de l'héroïne qui est
en pleine admiration devant devant
carole un personnage donc jouer avec
cate blanchette tout en maîtrise presque
en artificialité mais vraiment très très
très juste et l'image l'image de ce film
est sublime c'est infini qui nous parle
donc de l'imagination amoureuse et aussi
du poids de l'intolérance sur sur nos
vies
à gauche
le temps
ou dur est toujours cinéma à l'ugc
ciné-cité skywest organise vendredi 12
février à 20h15 l'avant première du film
la vache en présence de toute l'équipe
avec notamment lambert wilson jamel
debbouze et fat sa bouille ahmed
l'histoire d'un petit paysan algérien
fatah qui rêve d'emmener sa vache au
salon de l'agriculture à paris
l'occasion d'aller de rencontres en
surprise pour de grands moments d'amitié
et d'entraidé
extraits vous avez fait une demande de
participation au salon de l'agriculture
ils te mettent la clé l'interdiction du
salon a décidé de vous inviter vouël
votre bassin
confiée à marseille tu appelles
monferrato important celui son beau
frère
non non pas mener d'attaqués sa couche
regarde vient de nous rejoindre en
plateau mari seal vient manuel bonsoir
vous êtes comédienne et vous intervenez
régulièrement pour l'association lecture
et dialogue
oui c'est une vieille copine
l'association lecture et dialogue parce
qu'elle était depuis en 1975 et non plus
40 ans 40 ans et le but est magnifique
puisque lecture et dialogues c'est
culturel
c'est le dialogue c'est la communication
c'est le savoir et c'est aussi des cours
des conférences donc c'est une belle
association
alors c'est ça elle fédère plus de 400
adhérents et mutuelles multiplient
vraiment les activités vous disiez
ateliers visites guidées conférences
tout ça tout ça pour des prix pour 20
euros l'année vous rendez compte
lll cri le savoir et les gens peuvent
pour 20 euros aller à paris aller
n'importe où à voir connaître des choses
sur tous les sujets artistiques
culturelles économiques etc et même des
ateliers pour faire travailler sa
mémoire
ah mais c'est absolument épatant il ya
aussi conversation anglaise de toutes
les langues c'est une belle association
c'est pour ça qu'elle dure aussi
longtemps et qu'elle propose d'ailleurs
une chose qu'elle n'a jamais fait c'est
à dire une dictée vous me direz c'est un
petit peu masochiste quand même les
dictées c'est horriblement difficile
mais il se trouve que ce samedi 13
février à 14 heures à 14 heures dans les
yvelines dont couche au château de
plaisir plus particulièrement au théâtre
robert manuel qui est à plaisir en plus
le théâtre est bien nommée parce que
c'est mon le nom de mon père en est
content alors c'est un très très très
joli lieu et bien va y avoir une dictée
qui réservait pour tout le monde à
l'envoyer vous vous pouvez être étudiant
tous les âges ça coûte 8 euros c'est
gratuit pour les lycéens
et donc il faut s'inscrire si on n'est
pas encore inscrit on vient à 13h30 et
vous subissez
le texte qui a été concocté par un
grammairien distinguer qui s'appelle
monsieur luc benz alors mode à quoi je
sers là dedans je vais vous dire je vais
dicter voyez vous je vais dicter et
après pendant la correction faite par
les professeurs je vais servir de
bouche-trou
parce qu'avec marc gold fait d'aero
piano et bien nous allons faire 30
minutes de chansons de textes du
spectacle que nous faisons sur paris
actuellement
voilà alors pourquoi avoir souhaité
justement investir le monde de la dictée
cette nouvelle mission pour
l'association lecture et dialogues et
bien écoutez je crois qu'il n'avait
jamais fait ça et comme lecture et
dialogues adore les mots faut bien le
dire est que c'est une langue vivante
vivante ne veut pas dire facile au
contraire elle a des mystères elle a
plein de choses encore très particulière
est pas facile du tout donc c'est un
petit peu non pas un travail
d'archéologie mais d'archéologie vivante
afin de que l'on dise mieux les mots et
que les sens le sens d'un mot éclatent
encore plus je crois c'est pesé les bons
mots je crois je pense d'ailleurs que ça
s'inscrit dans un contexte qui est
particulièrement favorable
oui ce que les gens se plaignent c'est
vrai de faire de plus en plus de fautes
d'orthographe
mais une réforme de l'orthographe qui
justement ouais nous avons célèbre guide
est exactement mais les gens sont
formidables parce que vraiment vraiment
je crois que les gens veulent du
difficile
du ludique et du difficile et la dictée
c'est vrai qu'on a tous des très mauvais
souvenirs d'école mais là je crois que
ça va être en plus très ludique
elle se fait dans un théâtre au théâtre
robert manuel samedi 13 février 14h donc
vraiment plus de raisons pour ne pas
rejoindre l'anict et samedi 13 février à
14 heures au théâtre robert manuel du
château de plaisir en présence de marie
sylvia est entre autres de toute
l'équipe de lecture et dialogues une
association merci beaucoup d'avoir
répondu à notre invitation mais fixant
est tout de suite et quelques dates
culturel pour votre week-end jeudi 11
février 19h30 et vendredi 12 février
20h30 à la mairie ce de trappes
adepte des textes de pierre desproges le
metteur en scène michel didym puise dans
son fameux manuel du savoir à usage des
rustres et des malpolis pour nous offrir
un spectacle irrésistible et jubilatoire
vendredi 12 février à 20h30 rendez vous
à la ferme de bel ébat de guyancourt
pour deux solos de danse réunis dans un
concentré de
ness de sensibilité d'intensité
conjuguant le geste minimaliste à une
virtuosité extrême et enfin samedi 13
février à 21h venez assister au concert
de la grande sophie au prisme
d'elancourt l'une des filles du rock
français les plus à l'aise en scène soit
vous entraîner sur des rythmes rock pop
avec des textes un brin mélancolique et
c'est la fin du kiosque pour cette
semaine émission à voir et à revoir sur
notre site internet
merci de nous avoir suivi on se quitte
en musique sur un morceau de la grande
sophie très bonne soirée à tous autour
du lac
d'abord
cet autre père
cette horreur
tout cela est
devant